complément d'enquête sur Gérard pardu on
va revenir bien entendu sur les images
qu'ils ont mis sur Twitter il y a
plusieurs extraits qu'on va vous montrer
dans un instant et c'est vrai que
l'acteur gérarde pardic laatoile depuis
le début de l'après-midi après que des
extraits de lui étaient diffusé sur X
tisant le complément d'enquête de ce
soir ces extrrait ont déjà été visionnés
des millions de fois sauf que les images
n'appartiennent pas à complément
d'enquête mais ont été volés à Yan wax
ça déjà faut le dire c'est des images
qui ont été oui j'ai parlé avec yanx
avant l'émission et j'ai un scoop pour
vous qui remet en cause toute cette
version allez nous le dire dans un
instant vous allez voir c'est un truc de
fou euh ce qui se passe que j'ai les
dernières infos ériic et vous allez voir
comment ils se sont procurés les images
c'est absolument énorme vous allez nous
dire dans un instant puce qu'on va voir
les images et je voudrais parler aussi
avec avec Fari d'avant qui connaît bien
Gérard qui va nous dire ce qu'il pense
de tout ça et vous allez nous lire après
le le le le communiqué de Yan MOX et
vous VZ nous dire comment ils se sont
procurés ces images volées complément
d'enquête c'est absolument fou
euh on va revoir les images alors
euh voilà on va voir les images alors
les
images elles sont elles sont elles sont
c'est du Off en fait hein ce qu'il faut
dire éic nolo en fait c'était pendant un
reportage donc avec Yan max donc c'est
un film qu'ils ont fait on en a parlé
ici Yan Max était venu nous voir est-ce
que vous pouvez expliquer le contexte
alors euh il a MOX tourne un film en
Corée du Nord avec Gérard de pardu alors
déjà il y a une promesse parce que la
Corée du Nord c'est une dictature
ubuesque et puis de par Dieu c'est le
personnage en couleur que nous
connaissons euh complément il y a
évidemment une version de 2h3 parce
qu'il y a une affaire dans l'affaire
hein il y a une version de 2h3 qui est
séquestrée par le producteur déjà
première chose deuxièmement il y a 18h
de roche qui ont été mis à la
disposition de compléments d'enquête et
complément d'enquête publie fait fuiter
euh certains extraits et évidemment
c'est comme nous quand nous parlons dans
un cercle privé Gérard de pardieu tient
des propos qui ne sont pas politiquement
corrects mais je pense que chacun
d'entre nous a fait la même expérience
quand on parle en privé je pense qu'on
pourrait tous finir en prison parce
qu'on dit des trucs pour déconner mais
là où est le scoop c'est que Yan m'a
expliqué qu'en fait il y a eu un
retournement de situation écoutez bien
ce qui s'est
passé le producteur du film de Yan m sur
la Corée du Nord c'est le même
producteur que complément d'enquête
incroyable ils ont donc fait croire à
Yan MOX qu'ils allaient produire son
film avec de par Dieu en Corée du Nord
or ils n'ont ils nont fait croire à yen
Mo s'ils allaient produire ce film que
pour rassembler du matériel pour
complément d'enquête c'estàd qu'il n'a
jamais été question pour eux de sortir
le film de Yan m c'était juste un faux
film il voulait juste rassembler des
éléments à charge contre Gérard pardieu
donc les images n'ont pas été volées en
réalité depuis le début le seul but du
documentaire c'était d'alimenter
complément d'enquête ce soir quo ça veut
dire qu'ils ont fait ce documentaire
pour dans le but d'avoir ce complément
d'enquête après uniquement non c'est pas
en faisant c'est c'est ce que yanx vient
de me dire en en faisant croire à yanx
qu'un jour ou l'autre le film sortirait
or c'est la raison pour laquelle le film
n'est jamais sorti mais le film ne
sortira jamaiss on tourné ils ont tourné
ça ah oui mais attends on parle d'un
tournage en 2018ah oui et c'était déjà
du matériel qui é rassembbl 2018 j'étais
à complément d'enquête j'ai jamais
entendu parler de hisoire et bien voilà
c'est ce que me dit yanx que c'est le
même réalisateur et le même producteur
qui qui fait complément d'enquête ou le
document qui dit ce soir là je viens de
lire son tweet qui dit ce soir que les
les images n'ont pas été volées non
n'ont pas été volé puisque c'est la même
personne qui a juste changé de casquette
il est passé de documentariste à
producteur de complément d'enquête voilà
ce que m'a dit Yan MOX 5 minutes avant
l'émission mais alors Yan Max a fait un
communiqué également est-ce que vous
pouvez le nous le donner
Eric vous l'avez ou bien non je l'ai je
l'ai lu mais je l'ai pas sur moi alors
je l'ai parce que Yan me l'a envoyé
également parce que en fait c'est ça
c'est que Yan MOX pensait je vous le dis
hier soir Yan MOX m'envoie un message et
il pensait que les images avaient été
volées en fait il s'est rendu compte
aujourd'hui que c'était la même boîte de
production qui avait produit le
complément d'enquête et donc le film
avec Gérard de pardux et Yan max j'ai
découvert par voix de presse que des
rush de mon documentaire m'avait été
dérobé c'est ce qu'il croyait pour être
diffusé ce soir dans l'émission
Complément d'enquête sur France 2 il
s'agit d'une violation caractérisée de
mon droit d'auteur à plus forte raison
pour une œuvre inachevée dont j'ai le
seul droit de décider de la
communication au public la méthode
profondément choquante de la part de
tous ceux qui exploitent sans
autorisation ses images et a des fins
commerciales et sensationnalistes j'en
ai avisé la direction de France
Télévision qui prendra ses
responsabilité j'attends évidemment
faire valoir mes droits devant les
tribunaux Gilles c'est oui parce que là
on est d'abord dans une manœuvre que je
découvre mais KIC a très bien raconté
qui est incroyable c'est-à-dire que 5
ans avant ce serait ourdi j'enlève le
conditionnel cette ourd un complot
visant à accabler Gérard pardieu au
moment où au moment où complément
d'enquête le jugerait utile en utilisant
une production de Corée du Nord pour
venir à leur fin donc là on est dans du
vol il y a même une question de
propriété intellectuelle qui va se poser
de manière et de morale parce que vous
n'enquétez pas vous fabriquez les preuve
vous-même exactement donc là il il y a
quelque chose de profondément immoral
déjà que maintenant femmes qui ont parlé
quand même aussi Balay aussi d'un
reverement non non mais il s'agit pas de
balayer mais il s'agit de dire que déjà
souvent les procès sont remplacés par
des procès médiatiques mais si en plus
les médias fabriquent eux-mêm les
preuves en piégeant l'homme qui est
accusé je trouve qu'on entre dans une
dimension parle pas des propos
par grosortés vous dit c'est pour on
déconne tous en privé mais à quelle
heure on déconne en parlant d'une fette
comme ça il est
dégulasse je vous dis pas queouve je
vous dis simplement que si on enregistre
des conversations privé
ona question je dis pas contraireil faut
distinguer deux choses il y a les propos
il y a ce qui est dit et puis il y a des
méthodes on parle ce soir des méthodes
ça qui est en question c'est on découvre
enfin moi je découvre ce que dit permet
de justement de de mettre à
jourminel un violeur un agresseur alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on fait M on a
l'impression que c'est le far du
journaliste en fait il y a aucune règle
c'est n'importe quoi et moi ce que je
constate c'est qu'il y a de PO de mesure
à l'heure vous a dit ah non j'ai pas le
droit de lire le SMS parfois vous dites
on va passer les images on Paso passer
il à ils mettent les images ils
volent des rush ils mettent des
conversations privées au bout d'un
moment voilà évidemment on parle
pasire évidemment mais ce sont des
méthodes lamentables et quand c'est
censé être du Grand journalisme de
service public de se servir de rush off
je suis désolé c'est c'est interdit de
faire ça en fait al ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut l'argument je je je me fais
l'avocat des journalistes
d'investigation on va voir toutes les
images dans un instant l'argument qui
est souvent utilisé c'est du public
c'est que quoi qu'il arrive quels que
soi les moyens utilisés ce qui compte
c'est de mettre au jour des éléments qui
sont nouveau et que à ce titre là tout
est per pour l'intérêt légitime du
public alors pouro pour l'intérêt
légitime du public tu peux aller voler
je va donner quelques exemples dans les
cadres d'page on est allé fouiller dans
les poubelles pendant le Tour de France
pour sortir l'affaire la famille royale
on sait tous que la presse britannique a
longtemps fait les poubelles que il y a
eu des gens qui ont été sur écoute bon
voilà donc moi je dis pas que je
cautionnez-mo le parallèle jusqu'au bout
pour convaincre quelqu'un de dopage on
lui fournirait le dopage lui-même c'est
un peu ça qui il y a non là ça ne va pas
on on sort absolument de toutes
desontologies moi je suis pas sur le
fond de l'affaire je je suis pas là pour
défendre Gérard de pardu je vous dis
simplement que ces méthodes sont
inacceptbles donc les méthodes on va
rappeler les méthodes euh Éric nollo
donc il y a deux solution c'est où euh
comme vous avez dit ils ont fait ce film
dans le but de faire un complément
d'enquête plus tard puisque le film n'a
jamais été diffusé ça je pense que c'est
quand même compliqué pour eux de
d'organiser mais moi je pense tout
simplement que c'est le même producteur
et que le producteur il avait 18h de
rush 18h de Rush et donc ils en ont
sorti donc de ce film 4 minutes c'est ça
4 minutes de ce film 18h de rush donc ça
veut dire qu'ils ont regardé tous les
rush ù en fait qui n'ont pas été pris
dans le film que Yan MOX n'avait pas
décidé de sélectionner bien entendu pour
son film et ils ont sorti donc 4 minutes
et ce sont des extraits un peu off
normalement qui doivent pas être
diffusés Paris que ce sont des extraits
off c'est illégal c'est totalement c'est
totalement illégal et parfois ça ça
ressort de conversation privée c'est pas
du tout n J il n'a jamais été question
que ça figure dans le film définitif on
a le droit d'être un prédateur sexuel en
UF non mais ce qui est filmé c'est pas
desé par tu parlais de de fouiller des
poubelles là où c'est différent pardon
mais c'est qu' met dans la sauce
quelqu'un qui n'a rien à voir avec
l'affaire qui est yanx il fait un film
qu'il n'a pas publié on publie son œuvre
sans son accord enin c'est du jamais
vu les propos on est c'est clair les
propos ne sont pas acceptable ça on est
tous d'accord làdus bien
sûr voilà encore une fois on n'est pas
sur l'enquête on est sur la méthode dont
ces images sont parvenues au
téléspectateurs ce avant qu'on voit
d'autres écrit vous êtes un ami proche
de de Gérard de pardu quand vous voyez
tout ça vous dites quoi enfin on va voir
d'autres extrm moi je le connais je le
connais je le connais bien donc j'ai je
en fait j'ai pas la même vision moi
Gérard c'est un
déconneur c'est vrai qu'on a mis une
musique dramatique derrière c'est un
film d'horreur quand on le présente
comme ça si on avait mis une musique
drôle on aurait dit ah bah c'est sympa
c'est drôle ce qu'il dit il est amusant
il est trou ça choant pas moi
personnellement non le connaissant je
sais comment il est c'est pas il y a
rien de voilà il en joue un peu c'est
Gérard voilà c'est Gérard pour vous
donner un exemple c'est le seul qui va
être àable avec Poutine avec des gens
trèsés qui va lâcher une caisse quoi ah
oua et c'est Gérard d'accord ouais donc
ça ou ouais voilà donc voilà ça peut
choquer certaines personnes et puis
c'est normal pour Gérard donc c'est par
la loi de péter hein non bah sinon
castal serit en tle pour perpé ou il y a
rien de ouais c'est rigolo après c'est
vrai que ça peut choquer mais mais
connaissant Gérard c'est c'est c'est de
l'humour il est il est là il est il est
plein de déconnad il est voilà c'est
c'est un Bigard c'est bigar à la
française il parle de cul de de sexe de
machin ça
l'amuse non mais non mais je crois qu'il
y a deux choses différentes si dans le
film dans les roches il y avait eu des
images d'agression sexuelle de viol ou
d'agression sexuelle là il y a même même
plus de débat en effet ça peut servir de
pièce àchat là moi franchement je trouve
ça d'un goût déplorable je trouve ça
extrêmement plac je vais pas défendre ça
mais je je je je vois pas l'intérêt de
sortir ces images on voit quelqu'un qui
sort des propos déplacés oui mais faire
du buzz franchement non mais on peut on
peut on peut les sortir avec beaucoup
d'autres gens on a entendu dans un cadre
privé des gens sortir des ch im qui fait
qui fait qui
faitb ça c'est ça l'extrait qui fait le
plus parler je sais pas si vous l'avez
vu fille la petite fille
voilà les deux autres il y a plein de
gens qui disent un petit peu comme vous
je parle de ce seulement exactement
voilà ce que dit géraline sur les deux
sur les deux extraits qu'on vient de
voir j'ai plein de gens sur les réseaux
sociaux qui disent c'est Gérard de pardu
c'est les balfeus c'est Gérard voilà
comme vous venez de dire l'extrait qui
qui pose il y a une chose qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que on est quand même
en Corée du Sud Coré du Nord en Corée du
Nord pardon
euh si on se comporte comme ça sur des
choses sérieuses on se fait découper
c'est une dictature là-bas c'est pas on
n'est pas on n'est pas à Paris alors voà
donc c'est cet extrê ou ça c'est plus
problématique faut reconnaître voilà par
ouais mais bon c'est c'est c'est je vais
revenir encore on va dire ouais défendre
l'indéfendable mais c'est c'est de
l'humour il est là il est là pens qu'il
regrette ça aujourd'hui oui aujourd'hui
il il en souffre un peu parce qu'il en
souffre quand je dis un peu il en
souffre sou sou parce que il s'est pas
rendu compte de de l'impact que ça a
donné et puis voilà on s'est dit on va
se faire un Gérard c'est plus facile
qu'un voilà et ça c'est embêtant il dit
il se dit quoi là quand il VO ça il
regrette ça non mais évidemment bien sûr
qu'il regrette mon Gérard il est pas il
est pas parce qu'il est pas j'en parlais
avec lui il est tout SAF un violeur sauf
un prédacteur sexuel il est pas il est
pas dans cette folie il est pas il est
plus dans l'humour il aime rigolerourde
ouais puis c'est c'est c'est Gérard il
est peut-être encore à l'ancienne
méthode c'est l'ancienne époque il est
dans les années 50 à l'époque voilà on
avait du Coluche où ça sortait non c'est
surtout sur la petite fille même vous
JPH voilà c'est le truc même lui je
pense qu'il doit regretter ça d'avoir
dit
ça ça c'est pas possible oui
effectivement il do regretter
aujourd'hui ce sont des propos qui ne
sont pas acceptables moi je suis oui
bien sûr je suis même choqué de les voir
à la télévision de les entendre voilà
j'ai pas l'impression que c'est Gérard
de pardieu l'acteur qu'on connaît donc
là il a fauté il doit regretter il doit
être immensément triste d'avoir prononcé
ces paroles qui ne sont pas accept alors
sur les méthodes est-ce que ils doivent
diffuser ça des trucs comme ça parce que
ou bien est-ce que c'est juste pour
faire du buzz jaces cardos mais alors
bon moi d'abord évidemment je condamne
ses propos je les trouve répugnants et
cetera en revanche et donc je dissocie
le contenu des propos et et notamment
surt la gamine ça c'est absolument
intolérable il faut que ce soit dit mais
je je suis sensible à ce que dit no je
veux dire si effectivement ce film a été
tourné dans un but qui n'a rien à voir
avec un auteur dans le dos de l'auteur
pour finalement être vendu par le
producteur d'abord il y a un accord qui
est un accord qui ne peut pas être remis
en cause qui est que lorsqu'il y a un
auteur qui travaille pour une production
les deux doivent se mettre d'accord sur
la diffusion et sur le contenu des
images dans certains cas la production
donc là il faudrait voir le contrat dans
certains cas la production peut
outrepasser le rôle de l'auteur mais
c'est c'est quand même très très
problématique parce que ça veut dire que
c'est fait totalement dans son dans son
dos moi pour moi c'est une sorte de vol
moral exactement moralement ce que je
dis c'est dégueulasse de faire ça
Absolum voilà et la question que je me
pose pourquoi alors si les propos
évidemment qui sont dégueulasses et qui
sont choquants mais pourquoi ils n'ont
pas juste relaté les propos avec
quelqu'un qui dit voilà j'étais sur le
tournage voilà ce qu'a dit Gérard
pardieu mais là d'aller voler une œuvre
privée ça veut dire qu'il n'y a plus
aucune limite c'estd que demain tu vas
enquêter chez les gens tu vas frapper à
leur porte tu vas rentrer Ave caméra tu
vas fouiller leur téléphone c'est pas au
bout d'un moment ce sont des
journalistes ils ont certaines règles à
respecter on peut pas faire n'importe
quoi ça peut pas être le Far West et et
des femmes qui ont porté plainte et ils
on ils ont pensé que dans ce contexte
ils voulaient ils
voulent mais c'est vrai que pendant des
années on a pendant pendant des années
au nom de l'investigation il y a un
certain nombre de pratiques qui ont été
accepté parce que il s'agissait de de de
de de combattre des enfin de de comment
dirais-je de de oui de combattre de
mettre à jour et de combattre des
grandes des grandes idées et
personnages service juquête ça veut bien
dire qu'il un service qui décide de ce
qui est moral ou pas moral de montrer ou
de dire par la morale c'est pas le
service jdique qui se pê des limites JAC
on peut pas faire Norte
quo y a une seule question qui va la
dernière la dernière séquence qu'on a vu
c'est indéfendable tout le monde est
d'accord autour de ce plateau est-ce que
ça justifie les méthodes de complément
d'enquête selon moi non voilà je réponds
non et pourtant je suis choqué parce que
je viens d'entendre mais simplement
d'avoir monté un traackenard non
seulement contre de Part Dieu mais
contre Yan mois c'est une tromperie
quand même sur plusieurs années en en
espérant qu'il tomberait dans le
traackenard je trouve que ça ne ça ne
relève pas du journaliste ça ne relève
pas de la déontologie c'est de la
tromperie aggravée voilà maintenant ça
ne fait pas de nous des avocats de
Gérard pardieux surtout dans cette
dernière séquence qui a rien à voir avec
les précédentes hein je trouve que c'est
d'une nature très différente il vous a
parlé du complément d'enquête Gérard ou
pas non pas encore parce que bon pour
être honnête Gérard il a pas de télé à
la maison à part son portable d'accord
d'accord mais euh mais je vous dis il
est il est un peu il est il il est très
peiné par rapport à ça pourquoi c'est
pas lui pour vous ça sur sur ce dernier
extrait parce que ce dernier extrait il
pose problème à tout le monde voilà
vraiment les autres aussi mais et
celui-là vraiment tu vois moi que j'ai
j'ai une petite fille tu vois
voilà voilà on est d'accord voilà far
est-ce que connaissant en fait ça en
fait je suis pas assez objectif parce
que c'est un ami et et et un ami c'est
voilà on est là pour défendre ses amis
c'est comme pour donner un exemple
demain euh votre ami euh Cyril m'appelle
il est 4h du matin faride viens j'ai
besoin de toi viens avec ta voiture et
une pelle bah je suis là je me pose pas
de question ça
c'estésé jeis
dire Cali mais voilà en gros
euh non non c'était pour l'exemple non
mais ouais non mais j'ai vu oui sur la
méthode c'est hyper intéressant parce
que moi il y a quelques années à
l'époque au bon du CAN était encore en
vie j'avais fait un reportage pour
complément enquête sur l'affaire out TR
et j'avais piégé le procureur de la
République dans son bureau en caméra
cachée et j'avais enregistré des propos
qui étaient terrible qui était qui
allait qui allait dans le sens de de de
enfin qui allait contre son juge
d'instruction et dans le sens donc des
des victimes des des fausses accusés euh
beno duquen dans la salle de montage
lorsqu'il a vu ça et qui m'a dit c'est
pas possible tu peux pas tu peux pas tu
peux pas tromper le procureur de la
République il y avait encore cette idée
et il m'a dit on fout à la poubelleû je
peux te dire je peux te dire que jusqu'à
la fin de la soirée avec le rédacteur en
chef il y a eu un fight très important
sur la morale donc l'utilisation et la
façon dont tu tu acquiers des images et
un matériel elle est quand même en
question et là il y en a y a plus de
limite alors je vais vous dire on vous a
montré l'essentiel de complément
d'enquête ce soir pas la peine de le
regarder bien entendu
merciine merci et
suiteér